hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing now
that I got my mind's eye opened I
figured it's time to go to madness mah
mind and figure out what the hell's
happening over there because whoa stars
making a bleep er it's not an encounter
involuntary risk-taking is rewarded when
you find a hi-tech crate okay I got
punch cards I don't know what that means
but I got him I got one of those before
but I'm not under there
hi how's it going there friend oh are
you doing what's up here partner uh-oh a
mind that is not only guarded but
guarded by cultists uh-oh is right
thinking of getting to the bottom of
this all right sure you want one of us
be gone from this place interloper now
you know something bad is going down
nobody good uses the word interloper I'm
gonna Hornswoggle ya if you know what I
mean
chill chill I just don't have my mask on
I forgot it here after the last time oh
yeah where's your proof proof that I
left it here well I'm not wearing it am
i which I obviously would be if I had it
on me oh come on let me in I don't want
to miss the thing all right fine but
don't forget your mask this time
alrighty then well that worked out
mouthful II well ma fully well it worked
out MA fully well I'm gonna get
four-engine so I can get this goddamn
loco weed got it nailed it green thumb
yay yay I got a green thumb now I don't
know hi hello Cultus hello hello there
fellow cultists what go away that's not
very friendly this is Ana knitting
circle where's your mask anyway I forgot
it somewhere hello what happen to your
mask I modified it and made drinking
difficult what happened to your mask
I'll be right back yeah how what's up I
got some rocks yeah the master gave them
to me you wanted me to have them
okay what's cool about them they're mine
don't touch me all right fine then why
you seem kind of injured I fell down but
master picked me back up that's nice
he'll pick us all back up he'll pick you
back up
it sounded like a threat when he said it
like that how's it going new mask who
dis okay so yeah that's a nice mask
hi why's your mask difference because
I'm the leader of the cell how can you
be down here and now know that well got
past seven different guys to get here
obviously if I weren't meant to be here
that would be impossible
I suppose so who's his master everyone's
talking about a great Dark Master
Roberto are you sure you're supposed to
be down here
sure sure it's fine it's fine don't
worry about doing Batman
how's it to what master of course can't
you hear him yeah sure sure can I sure
can
so I remember these spirals in another
mind
it says dear Jeff the big guy says to
stay out of here praise be Roberto
sincerely Jeff
my name is dev whose name is you I'll
fry bread over the five pounder goes
crazy when you go near these rocks okay
well there's a ladder there let's go
down okay cha know cha cha cha know
there are four buttons some [ __ ] row
sums at Bundy Viking ik l machine
machine so you stick him in the slop and
something happens I don't know what's
going on sure okay why not big cylinder
I got an L vibratos cylinder all right
bunch of paper guards all right all
right and they had a bunch of rocks all
right I don't know what's going on here
but I'm gonna get out of here I'm gonna
go to the buffalo pile Peter it's crazy
hot out of here the deserts the worst
you could end up like one of those
charred black skeletons clacking towards
you I'll fight him I'll give him a
little fight a shootin an eat up some of
them you hit none of them got them
[ __ ] all right fine
we're gonna mmm fish you a gift Gary
boynes my skin bang that's not enough
you finish out that one damn it Gary
white got be better than me buying if my
shooting Annie would have hit one of
them it would have been better
got a gold tooth though so that's good I
can give it to that later okay bones -
Lord of bones that is die it's a lot of
bones it's a lot of bones
wow wow wow what is it appears to be a
giant pile of buffalo skeletons why I
don't know guess beats leaving them
strewn all over everywhere that is
that's a lot of bones there's a lot of
bones okay alright buffalo Buffalo
buffalo Buffalo buffalo Buffalo Wow
alright well this seems culty I mean I'm
not just uh called names here but this
big ol P duck sized skeleton gross deck
size hippopotamus gross cruise Fieri
what's still in stalker all right well
there's a lot of those here a lot of
activity down that corridor chantings
shuffling of robes scattering of bones
scary stuff you really shouldn't go down
there alright okay alright what's down
here oh it's covered in big beakers I
got an oversized chemical bigger gallon
size all right great blood you have no
idea what you're trying to make are you
sure you want to mess with this stuff
yeah give it up me open up the blood
faucet and fill the beaker up halfway
milk less threatening to the blood go to
the milk
alright partially fill acre gets give me
some attacker just watch this [ __ ] steam
rises from the beaker is in reaction
intensifies the intense heat of the
reaction fuses the ekor spigot into a
useless massive metal how will it end
the box and what's left in the beaker is
yes tell me
when the reaction subsides you're left
with a beaker of a revolting black fluid
and what's even worse is that it's
useless revolting black fluid you pour
it down the floor train before it can
disappoint you and then discard the
beaker take that black fluid ha showed
you what's up wait hang on wait oh god
damn it I just came from that corridor
didn't I wait I want to go back oh I
want to go back wait through the bars
hundreds of buffalo human skeleton
hybrids I wanted to make milk milk
lemonade round the corner fudge is made
that's what I wanted to do I forgot
about I wanted to do goddamnit I would
have made fudge I know it would have
made fudge it would have a guarantee
flush it's good toilet it really should
use scented candles yeah sure
tell them now when you find him all
right wait huh kind of discipline slip
what's then looks like one of the
necromancer cults it's got written up
two more of these and they'll be
ritually eviscerated nothing personal
it's just corporate policy all right
fine then well that's weird all right
bones rule do they okay all right cool
uh is that gonna help me blend in hide
in if you settle it amongst the thick
black robes it's pretty comfortable wait
you wait and wait you finally hear some
noises outside there's a couple cultists
passed through on their way from
somewhere else you don't catch much what
they say but what you do here's acre
after blood way to go stud why is drew
Doug having so much trouble with this
wait some more Iker after blood do you
say wait some more you wait a while
longer in the cult is passed through
again this time you over here something
different no remember the rhyme milk
after blood rituals a died hmm
milk after blood rituals a dud occur
after blood okay
okay after blood way to go stud milk
it's milk before blood ritual is good
Doug why can't you get this probably
because it doesn't rhyme
okay so it's milk blood Iker milk blood
occur that's what it does that's how I
go no no Doug that's not a tremor blood
for milk is as obsolete as the word filk
that's kind of a stretch
so it's milk Lyde milk blood ekor got it
blood before acres start that soldier's
ticker Oh fundamentals of nextmax
gives you the raise skeletal buddy that
sounds bad why would I do that
oh do I have enough to lock-picking oh
no I don't okay fine ah I'm back here
all right so wait yeah
I really want to make I want to see if
milk milk lemonade milk milk lemonade
what's the reaction steam cause the
lemonade faucet to get clogged up how
will it end the boiling subsides what's
left in the beaker is fudge 23:23 give
me bad fudge you dumped the entire
beaker of fudge in your mouth and revel
in it fudge mental oh my god that's
amazing
milk milk lemonade milk okay yeah wait
another beaker milk blood occur yes
whew Chablis what no wait no wait no
wait why is it clogged up why is it
fused shut no milk boy dicker then I
goof it I goofed it didn't I I goofed it
real bad oh no at least I got my fudge
that's why I can be happy about fine
what's down here then it's slab alone
Colette's um Alice Doyle's do it what's
going on here what Oh loses scale we go
they get there tough - all right well
I'm gonna put this in my body all right
I'm gonna shoot them bang [ __ ] bang
Gary okay good
bang bang whomp it all right you gonna
get shot mmm not doubt you'll be affect
I must shoot you you bumped yeah Gary's
got him up what gear did bang bang
bang let's help that guessing guy can I
shoot that guy
if I gotta go in mono e mono Ray Romano
I fine I'm going in manual god dammit
why not stick with being a god damn sure
why am I not a bean slinger that's my
question
oh wait it's just a farming thing
alright fine man how do I clean the
goddamn thing I know I got to do that ah
reading material yes that's me woo I can
get good medicine let's you recover HP
and con big spleen more potions in a day
expert poisoner hmm I'll take big spleen
that sounds good I like my spleen your
chemical experimentations have given you
a comically oversized spleen trust me so
[Laughter]
how do I clean this [ __ ] there's no way
to clean it what if I just mess up
everything and I accidentally like what
if I what if I just absolutely bungle up
everything all right here we go
disgusting tainted blood all right what
about milk milk milk we're just gonna go
super milk I don't know how this is
gonna ruin it but let's ruin it then
melts it for some reason surprisingly
after the reaction concludes you're left
with a big beaker full of milk it's
pretty anti-climatic and now all these
are fused shut well what good golly gosh
is that gonna do me how do I clean that
alright fine you know what I'm gonna get
out of there I'll come back later
alright I gotta go oh yeah I gotta go to
the desert house I forgot I know this is
shifting gears right now but I gotta go
back to the desert house and see Oh
cheap wine all right well that's good
Barry not worried about that I got to go
back to the desert house and see if if I
boil up this thing maybe I can do
something about it besides killing them
all
be nice because I really don't know how
to get this all done oil the hinges oil
them you use last of the oil in the can
on the rusty hinges the gates will open
easily and silently nice alright you
creep up to the door you can hear the
gang inside you notice the door jamb is
busted prod from being kicked in there's
a crude hask made of bent nails
looks like the bandits impotent just
been locking it with a padlock from the
outside when they leave if you had a
lock you could turn this fortress into a
prison and let me go to dirt wather
I know there was a lock available
somewhere who wants to fight well your
dead-bang wants a fight no but are you
dead alright so if I go in here I know
there's someone that's selling a lock
and if I get a lock on that but boy
what's it gonna do for me not you yes
cuz was it you Buttonwillow was it you
Buttonwillow corpse of the cowboy Oh
proper burial all right what do you got
you got luck no where's your goddamn way
I know there was a lock alright I'll
come back to that okay I got to go to
curious cop sir
open it and four nails ranch punch great
we're going to curious cops I don't even
know a lot of trees here looking at all
these trees you'd have to if there's
nothing else to look at it and get a B
the leaping box shooting to bring us
here let's go down a bit
oh well vibrate oh alright sneaking on
my belly just to make sure no trees
sneak up on me oh hello shock weed plant
got shock weed extract all right sure
why not oh hello looks pretty tough and
pretty attentive alright alright not
that tough I'm a one shot this bad boy
watch this alright fine then you're dead
now so what good with that Oh
deafening whoa yay jumping for joy
wow that's a big teleporter machine is
not switched on but as an empty coffee
cup confounded contraption is dark and
silent the monolith is dark
teresting that's a big-ass teleporter
that is that is a big teleported like a
big way big way big teleporter I got to
go back to the professor eventually but
let me hit this mold military send
cemetery ooh crack of a rifle let bee
buzzes past your ear I call bullets let
be sometimes aah
let's fight him hey buddy hey buddy I
just died
okay well then that was fun antique
range fighter oh nice Wow I want that oh
my fing on my thing this is my third eye
still open by the way yes it is yes it
is all right military simile oh no Ituri
oh no that is embarrassing all right
it's your partner look through a gate
many of stone crosses those are graves I
guess military grave since they're all
the same and in such neat rows soldiers
yeah even when they're dead the officers
make them line up in formation funny
alright there's a shovel I don't need
another shovel keep up grounding the
shed the caretaker appears to have been
shirking his duties for quite a while
judging by the dust and cobwebs look at
the tools alright shovel under the chair
alright let's go about the desk alright
tiny paint jars alright Flyers for
memoriam oh okay well alright then
eternal flame Wow there's an eternal
flame here this is a burning under a
flame I'm pretty sure you're not
supposed to do that
no it's good fire not to wasting it let
Gary handle this Gary ambled over and
chats with the Goblin all right
hey they asking if one inquire we need
alright sure I'll buy a weenie oh I
don't want to trade off my Moxie for
that no thanks no thanks buck oh no
thanks buckaroo [ __ ] bear get out of
here with you stupid oh wow you can
visit an individual plot number I need
to visit 420 that's right blaze it ooh
okay
stop looting graves that no for one day
we'll stop for now
passing fair mycologist Bush after you'd
finished reading the book you
absent-mindedly misplace it while musing
about mushrooms drat
I'm so stupid all right now that we did
that I think I need to go back to the
ghost wood because I I didn't finish
this oh all right I'll show you
hey I drink this real quick guys are
good okay time for bangs okay welp see
ya intimidating six-gun I don't need
that if I was still a cowpuncher that
might be good for me hey need a drink
please beer please
bumper dank mum Fleur but now my middle
name is sneaky it's sneaky I'll buy it
got a bottle of ghost beer it's cold all
right well I got that why should I have
that I forgot why I needed a beer was
there anything else I've completely
forgotten yes that was it I just came
for a cup bottle of goes beer that was
literally it well that was fun
let me go back to bread would see if I
can solve some of their problems ooh
curious abandon wall damned well stopped
who investigated all right ah peculiar
hearing a tiny sound like a distant
high-pitched humming me too AHA a well a
well of sounds where water is not seem
to be coming down there the transponder
goes all right well I'll go down oh look
at you
where am I going now fairly nowhere
because everything's dead all right well
don't know where this taking me
whoo-hoo vibrate Oh chamber habu no
statues masoom no buttons put in large
punch card okay whoa put in punch card
oh yeah put in punch card oh yeah okay
cool
but I'm learning words that's good
ooh I had a lot of these punch cards
okay well I've learned a lot of things
Hibou no terminal all right then well I
I there's a hobo no terminal huh it's
amazing that these teleporters still
have power to him but nothing else seems
as it does all right well that's good a
little bit of a detour on the way back
to Brad wood so let's keep on going
well time to shoot somebody yeah gonna
shoot you buying okay you're dead now
Thank You vibrations Capulin scapula all
right thank you
redwood I took care of your mail problem
all right well I'll take care of all
your problems then all right let me just
look at all your problems the logging
permit we're running out of trees around
here that's not good for my bridge the
town died okay I guess I'll check that
out oh that's why I need to go to the
dead ghost wood okay well let me just
get all of his problems lined up and
that way I can just freakin do the thing
yet soup shortage sure well bread would
bread bowls ah soup stuck load great
that's where I wanted to go skeleton
raids that's bad two more all right
Oh mutts brewery do I really gotta solve
all your damn problems old man all right
last one missing bread I got all of it
Baker boys sure thing we're going to
Al's ante or ranch
first then we're gonna go the rest of
the way open it up good sweet ah hello
cows hearing us I'm pretty sure the cows
can see us let alone hear us all right
let's find him got to jump on him this
time oh these guys ain't gonna get
nothing don't shoot him up shoot a
Marine
I'm so sorry about that cows but it's
too late for you time for you to go home
wow this place have really been blown to
pieces alright diary of Alexandria
Alexandria cool name ooh you flip
through the diary most of it is
uneventful describing the life of a
woman who likes books and isn't
interested in much else it ends with the
passage about a soldier from a nearby
forewarning or about some kind of danger
he wouldn't specify so she moved most of
her valuable books to the cellar
it took the ordinary precautions
boarding up the windows and not leaving
the house at night turns out that isn't
much good against can lose overdue bread
would book well found that one 12.5
percent of toast Oh
modern snake oiler thank you I needed
that one alright bad medicine quick on
the draw increasing your speed expert
poisoner I'll be quick on the draw that
sounds good yeah I didn't even read how
they lost that one and it was probably
gonna make me mad make me laugh alright
you pick up the Campbell and inspected
there's an inscription that you can
mostly read it says the cannibal came
from for treason and its interests
stamped around the surface this
bombardment was done by the army at Fort
treason
well that sounds bad how do I open this
goddamn cellar hopefully she's there
alright well I got that so let me go
over to Fort trees and see if I can get
some answers out of these [ __ ] oh
shut up
BAM alright you're dead right I'm really
really tough that that like that that
potion that really did it in for me for
man's they do not answering yes to
scavenge all right let's go scavenge
you look at the cannon to find Cameron
Demi culverin incise answer your
cannonball you look through the
rangefinder on the cannon but you can't
see any indication of anything you want
to shoot at you've decided not to waste
the ball alright what arrow with your
wastefulness jeez coward
alright what do we got every soldier man
is gone bulk around see if I can find
something what do we got here all right
sugar guns I can do okay alright
lock-picking all right kick open all
right
military school class ring that's a lot
of pistol damage alright good stuff
that's a lot of silver bullets Oh
private Matthews diary all right what do
we got there wait where'd they go oh
there it is okay
most of private math laws Diaries empty
places inks brought latrine duty stuck
out in the middle of nowhere our captive
as they decided nearby ranch was
actually an enemy spy outpost felt
compelled to warn the woman oh ok this
doesn't have any damn sure what the hell
sure leaving dirt water weird declares
his intention to start a mutiny but the
dairy ends with no conclusion to the
story interesting private Lemmons diary
alright private Lemmons diaries pretty
dry not very interesting day-to-day
duties captain simon becoming
increasingly agitated and convinced that
a nearby ranch is being used as a spy
outpost
Lema doesn't sound convinced but annoy
orders are orders dissent in the ranks
possible Muni rest of the pages are
blank was there anybody else's no but I
get this where did that come from
alright I'll do expert poisoner nice Oh
when you apply poison you flat three
times that much for Tinley you get so
distracted about thinking the new kinds
of poison that you misplaced a magazine
ah boring I should probably change out
for one of these rings alright this is
good
I mean I do love my nasty spittoon ring
but you know it's a good trade-off I
suppose
must have been where they stored all the
fire funny funny stuff buddy funny stuff
buddy poo alright let's quickly go over
to the old schmaltz bull rumery jump in
and see oh nice ok what's over here
smalls what's there buddy a smell what
is it a brewery the goblins have beer
beer
Oh booze we de fermenting the special
cactus juice is it good can't ever
remembering ok be right back see ya guys
have fun with that I'm gonna get a
floral ring mmm that's right makes
foraging random encounters much more
likely oh that's so nice ok
right now let's see what this yep that's
[ __ ] terrifying okay now I'm gonna
just uh yeah here we go see what hey
how's it going fellas too scared to talk
to you just totally freaked out about
the yeast beer hose you're not really
sure what purpose it must have served
all right well sample these contents
it's almost pure ethanol
blargh Oh dead guy's hat got knocked off
it's covered with yeast okay okay but oh
great this is great I have to wear of
you and your loved ones absolutely love
the smell of dough if you don't mind it
in your enemies hate it I guess all
righty then
Wow the yeast B seems to have killed
this guy pretty thoroughly so I've got a
crazy east boss there's barely broken
loose from the vats and eating some of
the bandits I guess they've brewed up
something they couldn't put down they
could barley control it you'll have to
hop too if you want to prevail all right
fine then all right we got the jump on
him big boy got the jump on him baby
right yeah BAM and then BOOM oh [ __ ]
dude right well out bang dad I should
have gotten the hard hat this is pretty
easy all right the remains of the
horrible beast I guess you could take
some back to the mayor it's probably
still good right
I got blob a big old glob of yeast just
right in the backpack no container half
a ton of yeast great this whole yeast
theft biz doesn't seem to have gone too
well for you boys
yeah oh jeez are you bounty hunter relax
the mayor just wants his yeast back he
didn't say anything about hauling you in
huh at least okay well the yeast is in
that revolting trial what happened well
we got bored of bread is all and know a
bit about brewing and we figured if we
came back with a couple kegs nobody
would mind if we stole that yeast no
offense but it seems like you are much
of a brewer Hey well ideally you
wouldn't end up with ravenous yeast
monster wasn't my okay wasn't my fault I
understand what happens the fats are old
we didn't clean them properly first I
think there were some frogs living in
one of them and you figured you could
use the extra hops ha ha ha if you're
sure you've figured it got it figured
out you could set up shop in dirt water
oh yeah it's turning into quite a little
metropolis I'd love to have my own place
I'll go check it out all right three
cans of beer can of
Waltz blue ribbon alright that's a lot
of damage that's a lot of extra damage I
don't know if I can imbibe that I think
I'm pretty full but maybe actually my
liver can take a good bit I'll drink
some of that
hmm hmm we can lukewarm great fun stuff
good stuff glad I did that
beer hose alright hey it's too grumpy to
talk to you
arrest him you're under arrest for what
stealing about two handfuls of East yes
and the sentence for that is what about
three days in jail and Brentwood does
not actually have a jail all right I'll
let you off with a warning what about
this dead guy yep he's dead all right
well that'll do it for this episode well
we're knockin this list off pretty quick
all these problems seem to not be doing
too bad for me
so either way thank you everybody so
much for watching god I love this game
let me know what you think down the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]